[Applause]
you can stop clapping I have no money
for you but I know why you're happy
today I'll bat me the same reason people
because the courts the courts of law
we're real [ __ ] happens
have fun finally confirm that a lot of
us have been thinking for a long time
I'm not crazy the president is an actual
trees in his crook you've heard of Black
Friday this week we had orange Tuesday
they are rolling up the members of the
Trump crime family man afford guilty
Cohen pled guilty currently singing
Allan Weissenberg chief financial
officer for the Trump Organization
singing we heard Don McGann the White
House Counsel is singing even Trump's
old friend who buried all his [ __ ] in
the National Enquirer David pecker
even pecker is not standing firm
oh I love this David pecker guy
apparently there is so much dirt on
Donald Trump David pecker kept a safe
they had a [ __ ] vault at the National
Enquirer with all his [ __ ] in it that's
how it took to keep all this and
somebody figured out the combination to
the safe it's the first four numbers of
trumps wait these convictions this week
this isn't even the main course which is
Russia this was just the stormy Daniels
appetizer look the campaign manager
guilty the personal attorney guilty the
deputy campaign manager guilty the
National Security Adviser cabinet
meetings are now are going to be held on
a visiting day
I say all of trumps lickspittle
apologists on TV they're like oh now
just being friends with Donald Trump
makes you a criminal apparently
apparently that is the case by the way
one sign you might be a crook your
lawyer is going to jail that's a little
hint oh Michael Cohen Trump Boyd did is
he turned on Michael Cohen Trump tweeted
out if anyone is looking for a good
lawyer I strongly suggest don't retain
the services of the guy I picked as my
lawyer for the last 12 years
and then besides Manafort and cohen and
flynn and gates all these people going
to jail the two Republican Congressmen
who were the first two to endorse Trump
Chris Collins Duncan Hunter they're
going to jail so many Republicans going
to jail who's going to be left to lock
up Hilary now if they lock up any more
white Republicans the white NFL players
are gonna start taking a knee
so so now we are in the time where Trump
has to start distracting speaking of
white he's deeply concerned this week
suddenly about the plight of Africans
specifically the white ones I have asked
Secretary of State Pompeo to study the
situation in South Africa will form
seizures and large-scale killing this is
this [ __ ] idea that the foreign that
the blacks in Africa are killing the
white farmers a conspiracy theory
propagated by white supremists and when
I say white supremacists I mean Fox News
this is something this is something he
saw on Tucker Carlson and and by the way
I always go by the rule if you want to
know what's going on in Africa ask a guy
named Tucker
I swear to God trapeze like a drug dog
for white victimization he can smell it
out anywhere
if Trump traveled to the deepest reaches
of space he would say why aren't there
any white holes so so that's distraction
number one distraction number two was
always you know the hostage situation he
said in an interview today if they tried
to impeach him the stock market would
crash and everybody would be poor yes
just what every stupid boyfriend says
you know if you break up with me you're
gonna regret it
you're probably right Donald we're
making a huge mistake we're gonna regret
it for the rest of our life heart emoji
crying emoji delete contact info on the
distraction front when all else fails to
go to the bottom [ __ ] of excuses go to
town on Jeff Sessions right every unfair
thing that ever happened to Donald Trump
is because Jeff Sessions would not
recuse himself but Jeff Sessions fired
back finally he yes he said while I am
attorney general just justice will not
be improbably influenced by political
considerations finally
finally answering the old-age question
do elves have balls